you know I'm you know jumping on this
with you at the last minute so you can
refuse to talk if you want but it's a
dude story so I'm sure that people will
enjoy it can you tell the story when
your family came to visit you and
they're in with the weather women were
scantily clad women had the horns and
everything in their head recount that
this is pretty great yeah my you know I
always like to include my I told you
about my wife being such a part of my
work and I was like her to come to the
set you know whenever she was but at
least once for the shot you know and she
hadn't come for the Lebowski show so I
think it oh this is gonna be the dudes
dream you know it'd be kind of a Busby
Berkeley kind of you know things will be
fun for the girls they were all you know
you know maybe six eight and nine
something like that and ensued be
wonderful and then as we're preparing
the scene I realized no it's not the
Busby Berkeley scene there were shooting
or that was kind of later in the day but
the first thing we were shooting that
day was the scene where the dude flies
under the bowling pin Corinne's you know
that's what we called him these little
girls with the big bowling pins on their
head between their legs you know and
he's looking up you know vaginas of all
these bowling pin currents and so I said
why did you invite your wife and
children to stay what it done and there
they are and I say well I'm telling them
tell me so I said so if I say I think I
think I'm gonna get with the program and
you know you know just relax and stuff
and so I I go up to the I have a wide
Lux camera I'd like to take pictures you
know well I'm making movies and I go up
to the main dancer you know the first
one I'm gonna look up inside you know
and I say you know game is is a great
photo opportunity mind if I take a
picture you know and she looks at me and
she says by all means dude get on my
little my little lose it was actually a
a skateboard and I got on the skateboard
and I I'm getting ready and I got my
camera okay and their rehearsal you know
and I action I'm being pulled and I
snapped my the camera and I say my god
that woman has a huge top sub of hair
coming out of her leotard the pubes are
just you know insane and then I go to
the next one and they're even more
glorious and I know underwear you know
I'm saying my god and finally I find out
that the girls went to the makeup man
and shoved you know crepe air you did
they're really good times and thank God
they were all wearing merkins my my
stand-in Lloyd Catlett who had we've
made sixty films together he's kind of
my constant thread through everything he
knew about it and told my wife and girls
so they were in our then cut me some
slack
[Laughter]